[Musik]
hallo
heute gibt es ein basic kochrezept ich
werde nämlich pesto zu bereiten
photofast ziemlich gerne auch gerne
grüne vergibt aber mein anderes rezept
dazu fenster besteht aus getrockneten
tomaten auf amüsante und olivenöl und
pinienkernen dessen so die
hauptbestandteile und wer es gerne zu
nudelgerichten oder auch mal als
aufstrich zu getrocknetem blut zum
beispiel und es ist wirklich super
einfach herzustellen
viele kennen wahrscheinlich nur fertig
offen klar aber auch das graphen
wirklich komplett verzichten und ihr
könnt zubereiten und dem kühlschrank
dann auch mehrere tage lagern wobei bei
unfällen ist eigentlich nie so ganz lang
sag ich mal kurz zutaten wie pesto
brauche stunde scampi mit 200 gramm
getrocknete tomaten die waren in öl
eingelegt und dieses öl verwende ich
auch dafür brauche ich schon auf 60
milligramm
und freilich nicht genug war fühlt ist
einfach mit normalem olivenöl auf 100
gramm tafel bankett eine prise zucker
knoblauchzehen nach belieben gerne zwei
esslöffel balsamico vier esslöffel
tomatenmark und etwas bei dem zuerst
einmal die vielen kennen sie kommen in
einer pfanne ohne fett in werden jetzt
darin gepostet und damit die farbe
bekommen wir ihn kennen und sich zu
geben ein bisschen feuer viele machen es
auch mit sonnenblumenkernen aber ich
finde nicht einfach nicht nur original
und ich hing mit pinienkernen schmeckt
einfach besser
man muss auch das zu bedenken dass man
gar nicht so viel fest opel benötigt das
heißt es zieht sich ja dann auch ein
bisschen unruhe auch nicht die komplette
menge machen man kann ja auch erstmal
nur die hälfte machen und einfach mal
probieren auf einem schmeckt
[Musik]
problem wirklich perfekt auf intensive
natürlich auch besonders gut du bist
hier auf dem teller damit schneller
abkühlen und kann in der zwischenzeit
schon mal für das pesto zubereiten mache
ich jetzt alles klar
aber ihr könnt zum beispiel auch ein
start mit immer schief geht auf denn ist
erstmal gehen
den werde ich jetzt fein reiben und habe
deswegen da oben eine reihe schreiben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nämlich die reise scheibe raus mit
messer nämlich benutzen da kommt jetzt
die getrockneten tomaten mit wein auch
das öl ist kann man wirklich immer super
verwenden weil es auch die ganzen
kräuter beinhaltet ansetzt wenn ihr kein
pesto macht und das öl noch übrig hat
von einem getrockneten tomaten dann hebt
auf jeden fall auf auch zum anbraten zum
beispiel und da die länge ist nicht
aufgezeigt hat musste ich noch mit
normalem olivenöl den auffüllen
sein kommentar
dann kommt da die knoblauchzehen und
natürlich den tomaten geschmack und
gleich die säure ein bisschen aus wie
die last von mir weg wenn die ladies
essen später mit meiner kinder aber ich
persönlich wird natürlich auch noch mit
rein geben weiter bei noch später auf
die fertigen nudeln mit drauf geben dann
balsamico essig und habe hier balsamico
sehen weil es einfach einen spitz-
möglicher schlechterer balsamico essig
wer noch auf tomatenmark und zu guter
letzt ein bisschen pfeffer salz promis
hier nicht ständig mit den tomaten sind
schon sehr günstig und pasan ist auch
für falsch ich deswegen braucht man das
hier auf keinen fall kommt noch der
deckel drauf und es wird jetzt ganz rein
berührt und gleich gebe ich noch die
pinienkerne mit der vor
[Musik]
was koche mir aber jetzt fertig und
damit gleich abgefüllt werden kann habe
ich es hier ein paar einmachgläser
inhalten ba vier minuten abgekocht
werden einfach alle keime abgetötet und
bleibt einfach länger haltbar
ich hol mich hier raus ganz vorne
spielen
deshalb droht das könnt ihr jetzt an
dieser stelle abschmecken
das heißt wenn salz oder verfehlt oder
im finish gerne an dieser stelle noch
hinzufügen oder kommst du auch ein
bisschen teurer also noch es sich zum
beispiel balsamico es der perfekte
moment
jetzt nehme ich das klar und für das ist
schön ein
am besten absichten dass die luft
entweicht und es ebenso länger haltbar
bleibt macht für mich den großen teil
nur einen kleinen teil völlig noch
abgeben bekommt dann meine mama auch
gerne verschenken alles geschenkt auch
für küche machen sie zwischen klub und
damit länger haltbar bleibt kombis
anbietern olivenöl punkt bekommt einfach
keine luft bundesland schon halb wahr
ich würde dafür in den kühlschrank
stellen und jetzt fragt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich was machen wir uns mit
dem pesto diese fenster können jetzt
verwendeten und zum beispiel nudeln gibt
es ab kochen und dicke nudelwasser
auffangen und dann je nach belieben 12
erster für produktion mit den nudeln
vermischen und mit dem nudelwasser so
verteilt nicht auch richtig schön oder
indoor foto pesto und streicht zum
beispiel aufgebracht für das bargeld
auch sehr gut oder nachbarn hermann
färber was einfallen
ich finds auch ganz lecker wenn man zum
beispiel falschen droht mit roten
peugeot macht habe ich auch schon ein
rezept gemacht dafür linke ich das
abseits auf jeden fall
und falls ihr befristet nach machen
wollt geht auf kellys - dr
dass sie jetzt noch mal ganz genau im
kühlschrank ist das pesto übrigens etwa
ein bis drei wochen haltbar muss nur
darauf achten dass immer noch nicht
olivenöl oben drauf ist und es eben
keine luft dran kommt und das wird immer
mit einem sauberen löffel entnehmen da
passiert eigentlich normalfall nicht
also viel spaß beim nachmachen und für
mich ist wirklich die perfekte rezept
idee denn ich kann es mal schnell nach
der arbeit zu bereiten und habe ich mich
arbeit also willst du nicht normal
[Musik]